خلال انعقاد الدوره الثامنه والستون
للجمعيه البرلمانيه لحلف شمال الاطلسي في
مدريد اسئله كثيره عن مصير الحرب الروسيه
في اوكرانيا وعن مستقبل امن الطاقه في
اوروبا وخطر اتباعيه الطويله ثم اجماع على
ضروره ايجاد مخرج دبلوماسي للحرب الدائره
في اوكرانيا لكن ليس على حساب الشعب
الاوكراني كما يقول الامين العام
لحرف الناتو
طبعا نريد جميعا لهذه الحرب ان تنتهي يجب
ان ندرك انها ستنتهي على الارجح على طاوله
المفاوضات لكننا نعرف ايضا ان النتائج هذه
المفاوضات مرهونه بميزان القوه على ساحه
المعارك
رئيس الوزراء الاسباني قويه
كي يدعم اوكرانيا وشانها وان يحترم وحدتها
الترابيه وسيادتها الوطنيه وقدرتها على
اختيار مستقبلها بكل حريه
على تجنب المواجهه المباشره مع روسيا رغم
اعتباره ان مزيدا من التصعيد الروسي سيدفع
الى مزيد من امدادات السلاح اليك